au cours du dîner des chroniqueurs
guillaume genton à
faut pas commencer par celle là on va
pas commencer par ça après le dîner des
coûts
quoi ah oui après le dîner des
chroniqueurs giraldi n'a eu des
problèmes digestifs et a critiqué le
restaurant choisi et payé par cyril
qui agissent à 10 8 face est un
chroniqueur anonyme non franchement je
sais très bien c'est vraiment elle a
adoré en plus oui mais c'est vrai alors
il faut saluer la dame qui était
formidable ils veulent aller bouffer
gratuit ça on était chez nous on sait
bien on chante on se fait passer pour un
grand joueur de foot mais nos choux
qu'outre des enfants de 14 ans pour être
sûr des dénés
c'est brassens et de la calomnie
effectivement en train devenir
footballeur professionnel et je vois
bien qu'on essaie de marc garneau
maladie décembre on a la vidéo mais non
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
c'est à tokyo tu vas on va l'amener avec
lui à l'attaquer de padilla au matin on
va vous avez vous des clous avec mike
horn plaisir ah bah oui plaisir voici
avec saba les chéris après 1 p
après un pet foireux benjamin castaldi a
craqué son slip et s'y retrouver les
parties a l'air drôle auch gilles verdez
les photos
non castaldi on attend des [ __ ]
surveillera la souplesse la parole est à
la défense sur l'arrivée dans la creuse
langage corporel donc peser vous écoutez
moi donc en fait c'était lundi
effectivement il y arriver même en sous
vêtements dans la loge sous vêtements à
l'hygiène douteuse
craquer devant nous comme l'ensemble de
sa personne qui a craqué devant nous
rebat en bas rien à ce moment là bah oui
ça sert la wii
[Applaudissements]
il est toujours aussi sexy cette photo
est libre et de droits
sacem à la tvh où kate a narré c'est la
vérité on allait arrêter ou prennent pas
dire que c'est pour nous un béret ça je
ne leur ai pas je n'aurai pas nier mais
c'est pas la peine dont la photo est
très bien cette photo m'a écouté et m il
faut le dire les choses là et mike horn
et écouter les mac
à cyril n'a pas fait vibrer de cadeaux à
jean michel maire pour son anniversaire
en affirmant à la prod que
financièrement l'après coville était
compliqué pour lui
qui a dit ça c'est pas nouveau ça le
toit c'est la loi mais en revanche est
ce que c'est vrai que c'était tir
lanières ceinture michel mr qu'on
embrasse travail alors je lui ai écrit
un magnifique d'un beau savez c'est un
parfum bas parfois sa maison de cadeaux
mais attendait non non non à vous
magnifique magnifique hu est magnifique
et est accompagné d'un présent j'imagine
la nasa futur même
nom mais le cadeau va arriver
il va arriver comme le cadeau qui devait
arriver le 30 août pour ma personne
alors oui alors oui vous ils arrivent
pour moi il a été bloqué parce qu'on a
beaucoup de pub mal avec les pièces
détachées avec le comité a eu
heureusement les dégâts j'ai toujours
pas une voiture bah oui oui messieurs
motards oui sinon l'importance de
celui-ci s'est pas détaché qu'est ce
qu'elle dit
qu est ce qu a dit novès a dit l'agent
touré prétexté un séminaire de travail
en décembre avec delphine wespiser alors
qu'il n'a aucun projet pour elle c'est
juste pour la pécho mes notes je caresse
oui j'avais les séries le millésime
je suis vraiment navré parce que je vous
aime beaucoup et en fait vous êtes
invités un séminaire a prétendument de
travail par monsieur genton alors mal
rasé c'est en alsace j'ai enquêté alors
je peux pas dire où c'est pour protéger
mes sources
j'ai appelé le chalet est un curé ou
d'un film que dans cet endroit un chalet
de luxe il y a une seule chambre non en
fait
j'ai effectivement organisé un séminaire
et de fines j'ai plein de projets pour
est vrai est en fait je me suis fait
avoir par le propriétaire oui ce qu'il
n'y a qu'un seul lit je suis très déçu
juste quels sont les produits puisque
oui alors il a proposé première bêta
fine tu m'en aurait parlé en fait non en
fait il m'a proposé de partir se mettre
au vert pendant trois jours pour se
reconnecter à la nature moi je lui ai
proposé ça aussi j'ai dit ok je suis la
bonne personne pour te mettre au vert
il a dit très bien on le fait on t'a
région j'ai dit pas de problème j'ai dit
je regarde pour un chalet il a dit non
t'inquiète moi je regarde je même mis un
petit truc sur un stade pour demander
aux gens s'ils connaissent un chalet
sarr dont vous allez vraiment partir
tous les dons pas mais je vais y arriver
avant noël et la nature est arrivée au
sprint avec la nature en ville je vous
serais pas d'excès damon méditer
du footing vous avez confiance en lui a
bien sûr bah oui bien sûr non mais vous
m connecte avec michael savage
hama castaldi se croit encore star il a
imposé son chien au dîner des
chroniqueurs alors que le restaurant
n'accepte pas les animaux pour raisons
d'hygiène
et quadistes à choquer nous avons été en
plus on nous avait précisé pas avec
notre +1 et lui il arrive avec sa chaîne
en juin mais ça fait un peu impuissant
dans sa cage et moi on nettoie j'ai
trouvé ça très choquant
les chéris alors ça j'aime pas du tout
ça cyril hanouna a offert des pizzas ses
équipières après le record d'audience
mais pour se rembourser il a demandé aux
équipes de participer financièrement
valérie bénaïm c'est vous la source
très proche des équipes de production
oui et il semblerait qu'effectivement
dans un geste d'une bonté pas du tout
alors je vais vous dire exactement ce
qui s'est passé hier dans un prochain
j'ai offert les pizzas toute la boîte
mais et après je suis passé parmi eux
jeudi tony ce que vous pouvez
[Rires]
je suis un peu ric rac en ce moment de
jésus dit le c'est le geste qui compte
oui voilà et et voilà je vous le dis
voilà à benjamin castaldi urines la
porte ouverte et ne tire jamais la
chasse quand ils rentrent au net à
lakanal factory oui c'est vrai salut mon
rêve ça va me vous êtes vous êtes un
grade ou ont fait de ces vrais moments
non non j'en ai dit non mais c'est vrai
que j'oublie oméga vous je vous dis je
vous adore mais
vous avez une hygiène douteuse
est d'accord avec moi qui radient
parfois oui j'ai vraiment l'impression
gym bien sûr c'est très choquant
après c'est ben beau c'est parce qu'il a
une femme très très propre et très
soigné et donc elle pourrait pas
supporter cannois dont la dérive alors
là il ya un truc au restaurant une jeune
fille aurait draguer ouvertement syrie
dans dix ans je suis prête à tout on
veut connaître la suite c'est parfois
mais c'est plus travailler
quoi qu il a redit que rang de nîmes qui
veut garder son travail
explique de téléspectateurs c'est une
jeune fille qui est venue nous voir et
bien fier très gentil très très gentil
est la leur et nation voilà tony ça n'a
rien à voir
nous avons aussi plus elle a parlé
longtemps à isaiah berlin et rooney
gilles verdez au dîner des chroniqueurs
valérie bénaïm a littéralement poussé
tout le monde pour être à côté de céline
n'a fait que rire à gorge déployée
c'était indécent quel faux culs
gilbert décédé il fera extrêmement
choquant
ce
que vous dites en loge sur cyril c'était
énorme franchement vous ne soyez pas
dupes de valérie benaïm c'est la seule
chose que je veux
c'est que quand on rentre dans le
restaurant c'est cyril qui m'a dit viens
te viens t'asseoir à côté de moi c'est
vrai
genton se fait passer pour un des gan
pour pécho delphine ah oui or pendant le
dîner des chroniqueurs il a mangé de la
viande et du poisson
[Applaudissements]
la chronique aux anonymes c'est moi
qui était à côté de moi rythme et a
défoncé et merguez
et ici sur le plateau pour plaire à
delphine je suivais ganci vegan
saucisses vegan
un truc de dingue parce qu'elle avait un
fort qu on allait manger au resto il a
même du mal à trouver quelque chose
parce que moi je suis végétarienne lui
carrément été vega mais
c'est ici dit montus aux merguez
delphine s'est montrée du doigt même nom
mais delphine si j'avais une côte de
boeuf il en a pris la moitié
bana je te jure d'articles à manger du
poisson et de la viande au restaurant
oui je te jure
malheur tu as mangé une pizza
a mis ton nom lankais laisse croire
bernard montiel a pris un tel melon qui
l'a lancé lui-même sans en avertir les
équipes par hashtag avec son nom 6h est
six à sept avec montiel
et une homélie la prière il a pris est
il apte rien là ils apprirent mulhouse
meghraoui j'ai bien des émois c'est vrai
alors en fait figurez-vous qu'il a
appelé mme aux équipes de production et
tout à l'heure il était avec le
réalisateur qu'il a ce soir jean jacques
amsallem loges louées demandait s'il
pensait que c'est possible assez vite de
réaliser logo 6 à 7 avec montiel
beaucoup demandé à jean jacques
mais c'est pas mal aussi
pendant le dîner des chroniqueurs mardi
isabelle s'est fait draguer par un
serveur et ils se sont sûrement pas par
un serveur par un tir et ils se sont
exsangues échangé leurs numéros ils ont
même prévu d'aller prendre un verre
ensemble source cyril hanouna
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors oui mais c'est pas le garçon que
vous croyez c'est qu'on discute comment
on n'entendait rien à mes garçons qui
vous arrive est un garçon 36 ans voilà
c'est charmant à la table voisine et il
a terminé en me disant si ma femme était
pas là je vous invite à prendre envers
julie si j'étais mariée je l'accepterai
et là dessus je sors les tout vient du
fond à me c'est un bon jeune homme et
qui en sortant me dis eh ben moi je ne
suis pas mariée je vous invite à prendre
inversée dès ce soir je ne peux pas mais
je suis d'accord et on a échangé nos 06
effectivement s'il ya eu des nouvelles
depuis non j'ai pas il est à cobourg et
n'en a créés très bon et elle avait une
cote héros d'hier sachez que mise avec
les finales de potes tout le monde et tu
es sûr isabelle ballon mais je maintiens
du regio-tour n'est rien mais ils
étaient tous autour du collège sérieux
on a fait un prénom que tel au feu de
polenta
toujours que c'est vrai elle a l'air
sympathique et merci au dîner des
chroniqueurs mardi soir benjamin
castaldi c'est sifflé une bouteille de
rosé à lui tout seul oui
écoutez je n'ai pas mesuré c'est moi qui
vous ai servi
[Rires]
enfin que je suis pas une goutte et j'ai
bu quelques verres c'est vrai mais c'est
dur ce terrible pour cette belle
invitation ce vin est très bon merci à
consommer sans modération bien
évidemment alors après le dîner des
chroniqueurs gilles avoue être venue
juste ou pour manger gratuitement et
personne ne lui adresser la parole
[Rires]
je vous ai parlé un membre a tout à la
fin après deux heures
j'écris parce qu'il y avait des filles
montiel isabelle et gilles et vous c'est
vrai que c'est plus après voilà et qu'
il y avait mon chaton qui était tout
seul parce qu'ils étaient il avait eu
une année périlleuse l'avez vous avez
une mauvaise aventure les chéris alors
guillaume genton ça c'est vous bernard
montiel se vante dans les soirées
mondaines de faire plus d'audience dans
le 6 à 7 que lorsque cyril c'est cyril
hanouna qui l'animent ouais c'est un
succès car l'histoire alors elle pas de
se vanter dans les coulisses qui fait
des meilleurs scores non seulement que
machin mais aussi que vous mais c'est à
dire que moi parce que j'anime par mois
non mais que vous sur les mêmes cibles
star qui dit kim assure la partie sur sa
partie exactement dans les centaines
d'hommes enduits laquelle vous avez
alors pour mettre fin à cette mascarade
j'ai commandé des chiffres aussi
la bac est
meilleur que moi aller en classe sur la
cible des 15 34 ans donc les jeunes +
100 % cyril hamelin 25-49 ans pourquoi
125% si oui ou non les ménagères
très bien en tout cas les chéris selon
le tennisman dany le mode wenes numéro 2
au classement atp il vient de gagner
l'us open c'est un des plus grands
joueurs de tennis mais s'il me dit que
le récébédou cave medvedev c'est vous
qui avez fait cette peau car valérie
benaïm paraît que vous avez une vidéo de
daniel medvedev alors regardez c'est ce
que oui on a mis sur valérie bénaïm
regarde on paddle si je t'envoie cyril
hanouna j'ai jamais je pas là je vais
être un jeu donc je sais pas si je suis
bien ou pas bien apparemment j'ai
entendu de tous les joueurs de tennis
quand il vient il prend le racket et
j'allais là facile je vais déchirait
tout le monde mais apparemment c'est pas
ton facile je sais pas j'ai jamais joué
peut-être tu peux me battre j'ai aucune
j'enverrai cyril est donc c'est pour ça
donne avec toi c'est pour ça qu'ils
n'ont pas d'elle si je en tout cas la
première partie je vais jouer à fond
c'est dingue parce que même sur le
cicruit tennis et
discutés au cours du temps mais ça c'est
le numéro de modèle je suis fou de lui
sachez le dernière pukki c'est benjamin
castaldi je voulais c'est à dire vous
même parce que je
veux vous dire je vous dire cette poule
qui est fou ce qu'il a mais cette
tactique
alors cyril après avoir bien dîné à
lâcher des caisses monumental dans sa
voiture juste à côté de son lit diane
son collaborateur qui a manqué à chaque
fois de décéder
dépêtrer malodorant je vous jure sur la
tête de toute ma famille dont la voiture
en plus les derbys et
il y aurait alors la très bien manger
c'est vrai génie ni génie numéro là
voilà et gilles il dit cette phrase
incroyable dit bon moi je vois
franchement j'arbitrais pts est 2e
et manon il a lâché une caisse mais non
seulement dans un bruit ça mais non mais
même le cuir de la même hauteur du siège
vial qui était à côté le pot à faire et
moi j'étais dht crunch été choqué
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
il m'a déposée de gentiment chez moi je
suis sorti très très mal alors johnny
[Musique]
et moi j'ai une vidéo personnelle non je
m'y attendais nom
n'existe pas plus de place que c'est fou
s'est fourré salle d'imac t'inquiète pas
on partira ensemble et à
kayes à supporter pour y
dormir à côté de moi tranquille maïs
s'inquiète pas mon chéri